en una discusión de biología o de
evolución la idea de especie sale una y
otra vez y tenemos muchos vídeos sobre
especies pero la definición más común de
una especie es que es un grupo de
organismos que pueden cruzarse pueden
cruzarse y producir descendencia fértil
descendencia fértil por ejemplo en esta
imagen tenemos muchas especies de
elefantes modernos y sus ancestros que
actualmente ya no existen pero que están
relacionados con los elefantes modernos
actualmente en la tierra tenemos a los
elefantes asiáticos y a los africanos y
cada uno de ellos es una especie el
elefante asiático se puede cruzar con
otro elefante asiático y producir
descendencia fértil y un elefante
africano se puede cruzar con otro
elefante africano y producir
descendencia fértil pero no pueden
cruzarse entre ellos un elefante
asiático y uno africano no pueden
producir
fértil y eso lo sabemos porque hay
personas que lo han intentado pero la
pregunta más importante bueno en
realidad una de las preguntas centrales
más importantes de la evolución es cómo
se llegó a estas especies bueno podemos
encontrar ilustraciones como esta que
tenemos del lado derecho y del lado
izquierdo tenemos algunos dibujos
originales de darwin que nos muestra en
el árbol filogenético mostrando cómo se
ramifica una y otra vez desde las
especies madre a los diferentes hijos y
aquí podemos verlo con los elefantes en
algún momento el elefante asiático y el
elefante africano comparten un ancestro
en común y basándonos en este diagrama
podemos ver que también es un ancestro
común del mamut pero si profundizamos
más éste también es el ancestro de esta
especie que no conozco y así podemos ir
retrocediendo pero como se obtiene esto
como se da la especiación como es que la
variación de especies en una población
puede ser
tan diferente y que de alguna forma
pueden estar tan separadas unas de las
otras que no se pueden cruzar entre
ellas y producir descendencia fértil
bueno existen algunas formas en las que
podemos analizarlo la más sencilla o la
más natural que podemos imaginar es
mediante la separación geográfica y el
término adecuado para la especiación que
ya dijimos que es la formación de nuevas
especies el mejor término para indicar
la especiación debido a la separación
geográfica es a lo patrica o también
llamada a lo patria
a esto se le conoce como especiación a
lo patrica especiación se refiere a la
formación de nuevas especies a lo quiere
decir otro y patrica se refiere a la
tierra natal entonces hablamos de la
separación geográfica de otras tierras
natales y un ejemplo muy común son las
ardillas antílope si nos encontráramos
en el suroeste de eeuu hace mucho tiempo
antes
que el gran cañón fuera un cañón cuando
el río colorado solamente pasaba y no
había una gran separación en ese tiempo
existía una especie madre los ancestros
de estas dos ardillas que vivían en los
dos lados del río y en diferentes
momentos del año cruzaban el río las
ardillas del norte y las ardillas del
sur se podían cruzar entre ellas y
producir descendencia fértil todas eran
una sola especie pero con el tiempo el
río colorado erosionó más y más la
tierra y la roca hasta que todo se
convirtió en lo que ahora consideramos
como el gran cañón así que con el tiempo
esto se convirtió en una barrera
significativa por la que ya no se puede
cruzar una vez que esto se convirtió en
el gran cañón fue imposible para estas
ardillas seguir cruzando el río y así
fue como quedaron dos poblaciones
diferentes que comparten la misma
especie madre pero que ahora se
encuentran separadas geográficamente y
desde que fue muy difícil o incluso
imposible cruzar
ocurrió la deriva génica y la selección
natural los procesos evolutivos de los
que hablamos en otro vídeo en el que la
ardilla antílope de harris que vive al
sur del río esta ardilla y la ardilla
antílope de cola blanca que vive al
norte aunque se parecen mucho por lo que
podemos ver en las fotografías ahora se
han diferenciado tanto que se consideran
diferentes especies incluso ya no pueden
cruzarse y producir descendencia fértil
entonces la especiación alopática ocurre
por separación geográfica estas ardillas
no se pueden cruzar y con el paso del
tiempo sus genes cambiaron a través de
la selección natural y la deriva génica
pero qué pasa con las situaciones en las
que los seres se encuentran en el mismo
lugar
bueno teóricamente pueden seguir juntos
pueden interactuar pero existirá la
especiación la respuesta es sí y esa
forma de especiación en la que se
encuentran en el mismo lugar es decir
sin una barrera geográfica se conoce
como
simpática lo escribiré especiación
sin patrica ok y algunos ejemplos de
especiación simpáticas son un poco menos
evidentes pero hay un ejemplo que muchas
personas piensan que se trata de
especiación simpática justo frente a
nosotros
miren el nombre científico de esta
especie es raro le tipo mont ela es
originaria de américa del norte y antes
de que los colonizadores europeos
trajeran manzanas a américa del norte
esta mosca dejaba sus huevos y sus
gusanos adentro de esta fruta de espino
como la que tenemos aquí entonces las
moscas iban a los árboles de espino y
usaron la fruta para dejar sus huevos y
que las moscas jóvenes se las comieron
pero una vez que los colonizadores
europeos introdujeron los manzanos en
norteamérica podemos decir que un
subgrupo de rago letis pone la empezó a
dejar sus huevos en las manzanas y sus
gusanos crecieron adentro de las
manzanas y por eso es que actualmente se
han separado
no completamente en dos especies
diferentes porque en teoría aún podrían
aparearse y producir descendencia fértil
pero eso ya no ocurre aún cuando se
encuentran en la misma zona geográfica
además de que no es difícil que una
mosca vuele de un árbol de espino a un
manzano pero ya no se aparean entre
ellas y debido a este comportamiento en
el que unas deciden ir a las manzanas y
otras deciden quedarse en el espino
actualmente están desarrollando rasgos
diferentes que se seleccionan
dependiendo de esa podríamos llamar la
preferencia inicial sobre la fruta que
quieren usar para dejar sus huevos por
ejemplo para las que están en el manzano
su ciclo de crianza está alineado con la
temporada de crecimiento de las manzanas
mientras que el ciclo de las de espino
va junto con el ciclo de crecimiento del
espino así que los biólogos creen que
este es un ejemplo de especiación
simpática ocurriendo justo frente a
nosotros y se cree que algunos cientos
de años
incluso miles de años o más estas moscas
terminarán siendo dos especies distintas
que no podrán aparearse y producir
descendencia fuerte otro ejemplo de
especiación simpática tiene que ver más
con las plantas y bueno como aprendimos
en otros vídeos de khan academy los
organismos como los seres humanos bueno
en realidad muchos organismos que se
reproducen sexualmente son organismos
diploides tienen dos conjuntos de
cromosomas
por ejemplo los seres humanos tenemos
dos conjuntos de 23 cromosomas lo que da
un total de 46 cromosomas 23 de tu mama
y 23 de tu papá por eso somos organismos
diploides pero hay errores que pueden
ocurrir durante la reproducción y
errores que ocurren durante la meiosis
que pueden conducir a la polis proy díaz
en la que un organismo puede tener más
de dos conjuntos de cromosomas en el
reino animal
eso no funciona normalmente eso no
produce un embrión o mejor dicho un
cigoto viable pero
el reino vegetal esto se tolera un poco
más entonces podríamos tener una
situación en la que tenemos una planta
diploide y mediante un error en la
meiosis en lugar de producir óvulos y
espermatozoides a floyd es se producen
óvulos y espermatozoides diploides que
entonces pueden unirse para formar una
planta tetraploide es decir una planta
que tiene cuatro conjuntos de cromosomas
en lugar de dos y una vez que la planta
tetraploide existe solo podrá
reproducirse con otra planta tetraploide
o con una planta diploide miren aquí
tenemos a las plantas diploides en las
que funciona correctamente la meiosis
pero eso entre comillas porque este
error es lo que a veces ayuda a la
especiación sobre todo en el reino
vegetal y se pueden producir estos
óvulos o espermatozoides a floyd es y
por medio de la meiosis la planta
tetraploide produce óvulos y
espermatozoides diploides pero al
combinarse ahora se produce una planta
triple
esther y porque la separación no se dará
bien en la meiosis de esta célula si es
que se da el caso entonces con esta
planta tetraploide ha ocurrido una
especia ción y se puede ver como una
nueva especie esto es algo que ocurre
mucho y tal vez no podamos entenderlo
todo aún no comprendemos cómo es que ha
ocurrido toda la especiación que ahora
observamos pero podemos imaginar que
este es un mecanismo en el que aumenta
el número de cromosomas en ciertas
especies respecto a otras entonces
espero que esto les empiece a resolver
algunas preguntas y tal vez les genere
más preguntas porque este es un tema muy
interesante sobre cómo se forman las
especies y cómo es que surgen más dando
como resultado la diversidad de especies
desde que existieron sus ancestros